Netflix's it's chillin at pictures of
sabrina has invoked an unholy terror and
100 and a 150 million dollar lawsuit
from the Satanic temple I don't even
really want to talk about but we're
going to talk about it anymore - so
break down the devil in the details we
are joined by FIU law professor and
author of copyright class struggle
creative economics and social media in
the social media age
Hannibal Travis Hannibal walk us through
this why is Netflix being sued well it
seems like there's a brief scene in one
of the episodes in which the characters
go to a large room where there's a
statue of a goat-headed man with small
children looking up at him and there's
some evil scheme or something going on
in this room and the statue is very
similar to the Satanic temples statue
that they try to get installed at
courthouses as a First Amendment message
that they changed the historic picture
of the devil or Baphomet as a
goat-headed man into this more modern
version with children looking up at him
so they're alleging that they made that
Netflix made an unlawful copy of their
sculpture in the show and also used it
on social media and in various ways to
create confusion between the show and
the Satanic temple so this animal would
be a case of infringement then on their
on their their likeness and property
copywriting statue and Trademark in the
statue as a something that the temple
uses to distinguish its services from
those of other religions and temples Wow
well thanks for breaking that down
Hannibal um do they have a claim for
damages yeah cam it CAD well will this
hold up in court they might have a
copyright claim they'll have more
difficulties with their trademark claim
under the First Amendment the issue
they'll have what the copyright claim is
what is the fair market value really of
using this statue in a TV show is there
any history of licensing a statue like
this or this particular statue there was
a similar case similar but there was a
case against mayweather the boxer
involving the use of a beat or part of a
song and the court ultimately said that
there was no money that could be
recovered because they couldn't prove
the value of the song in that context
that same kind of an issue may come up
here got it got it okay look
that is why you don't mess with the
devil okay you are losers we say that
all day but true story ramble thank you
so much for chatting with us about it
and breaking it down it's a super
confusing but hey that's life right
alright have a good day
[Applause]
[Music]